you need to move faster as an investor
and the entrepreneur as i said need to
build products that are more agile and
more adaptive into what's going on in
the environment
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
hello and welcome to another exciting
episode of 20 minute leaders i am joined
today by a good friend and amazing
investor lee mozar managing partner and
founder of and ventures as a former
partner of i angels vc lee headed
partnerships and investor relations for
the organization worked with hundreds of
investors family offices and
corporations worldwide prior to that lee
was chief of staff to the israeli
ambassador michael oren in washington dc
and a senior consultant to blackrock lee
holds a bachelor's degree from tel aviv
university and an mba from kellogg
northwestern
lee moser welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you hey michael great happy to
be here
very happy to be here and ventures i
love what you guys are doing i'm a big
big fan and a big friend and and more
importantly at this point i'm excited to
hear about your journey your personal
journey how you've come to it to be an
investor in the vc world previously i
angels now and ventures but before that
chief of staff to michael orrin israel's
ambassador to the united nations and and
you know the journey is is non-trivial
a lot of lessons that i'm excited to
that you'll share with me hopefully and
and you know finish this conversation
with a bigger sense of understanding of
what are the different journeys that
people are undertaking how does that
impact their lives and their values and
understandings and so i've talked enough
lee walk me a little bit through your
own experience first how do you even get
to be chief of staff to the israeli
ambassador
uh wow okay so everything that we do in
life is basically our network uh and i
really believe in that the connection
you have in people what you're doing
people and the history that you share
with people
um i finished my degree in political
science sister in italian
i always wanted to work at the embassy
and then i opened a newsletter and the
newspaper is kind of the last lesson in
the university and i see that michael
orton became the ambassador
i knew his son joab which is a great
person has his startup himself
and i called him i was like listen how
do i get to the embassy and he was like
you are applying to the ministry of
foreign affairs i said no i want to talk
to your dad
make long story short um i did connect
with uh with michael oren
and i did apply to the ministry of
foreign affairs and after four or five
months of everything i got accepted
so that's how i got there
now what was the initial you know
motivation that you had that that led
you to and say i want to move to the
united states i want to be a part of
this delegation
i always like politics
always
find it fascinating and i think the
heart of the international relationship
of israel is in the u.s so being in dc
uh with a quite challenging challenge
time between obama and netanyahu
um was a place i wanted to be i wanted
to learn um
and it was a dream for a long time it
was a dream like since i remember myself
i wanted to be in the foreign ministry
so
very very cool now the day-to-day of a
chief of staff i i know what a chief of
staff does to you know a ceo
or president of a company but but what
does the chief of staff do in in diplo
in diplomacy world
so it's a combination i would say of
politics advisory public affairs
it's like the embassy in dc it's like a
little government so you have the
ministry of foreign affairs ministry
ministry of defense uh finance congress
whatever
and you need to be the person in the
middle that helps the ambassador to
facilitate between all of that
and also overseeing internal and
external politics and policy so if it's
between the offices in israel and
parties as we know it's not easy
when you have a prime minister for one
party and a foreign minister from for
another party or if it's between the
member of congress even you know helping
them understand each other when you're
israeli and they're american
and it's a lot of networking it's a lot
of networking
so so a lot of the things that you've
mentioned obviously i think can draw
parallels to
high-tech and entrepreneurship but i'll
let you do that you you finish your time
as chief of staff
is it obvious to you trivial that you're
going to go into venture capital and
you're going to go into the high tech
scene
no not at all it was very hard
i finished after being four years in the
u.s being in the white house like two
times a week in the congress in the
biggest parties
and really fighting in the core for what
we do in israel and outside
and it was really hard for me to get
back to israel
and
i wanted to influence and i thought that
really the best place of influence
making an impact is uh through
innovation and through uh what we do in
what we say the startup nation or this
ecosystem
everything we discussed in dc was
controversial
everything if it was the palestinian or
if it was iran or if it was other
matters the only thing that everyone
agreed on is that israel innovation is
it's the best
it's changing life it's helping life and
it's uh now it's even bigger than what
it was 12 years ago right yeah of course
i wanted to see my to see myself and
that's how i got into into tech
from basically public diplomacy talking
about tech
not really understanding a lot about
tech but
understanding that this is the bridge
to um
i don't know represent israel in its
best matter and this is how i kind of
start exploring it i want to be a part
of it
and so walk me through your own journey
as a venture capitalist and
you know i'd love to also understand a
little bit of how your your own
you know investment thesis
transformed or evolved throughout the
years as you've undergone a lot of
experiences a lot of investments
sure
um
so really kind of what we're doing and
and what is my thesis and my partner
royalties is is um
obviously we like to invest in
the best entrepreneur and best is also
great people that you want to work with
that you want to hear their opinion that
you understand that you know one and one
is three together
and we're looking to work
with entrepreneurs that are just like um
uh we had to talk about it but uh aiming
to the moon
and one to transform uh uh
entire industries
and it doesn't matter and we we're
investing super super early so for us
i would say the person itself and the
vision and obviously that mvp of the
technologies is important
but what we can build together
um and how we can be a good investor
right everyone likes to say a
value-added investor and for that we
build a studio like a place that an
entrepreneur and a company can get a
tech advice a uiux advice growth advice
and different landpads around the world
mainly in the us so
kind of answering all the gaps that
might have to uh um
right uh already starting take me take
me a few steps back then you know and
ventures the the it's a new vc fund
based out of israel
looking at israeli companies but but
it's doing it in a different way and
understanding with the more globalized
mindset that the world is connected
israel is not just the startup nation
it's a scale-up nation tell me a little
bit about you know the thesis behind and
because you started mentoring the
mentioning the the cooperation with
different companies and that's a big
part of adventures but tell me you know
take me back a little bit about what
what is sort of the thesis of this fund
okay so
the fund we call ourself a company
builder based fund
where as i said we invest early and we
help the founder build the companies at
the right
right direction
um
i think the most important thing is that
you we all know that we have amazing
entrepreneurs and they're super smart uh
i think the validation and the execution
i definitely
need help
obviously not for all but for many and
for us we're working with a lot of
corporates you can see them in our
website that we gain relationships for
the years
we are bullish on validation when we see
a company a part of what we do during
the due diligence he's helped validate
with different corporates and this
different expert matters that in the two
companies we invested a lot of them
become clients and that was the best
validation and the best amazing
and then the second thing is execution
and execution for us is uh uh
connecting to the global world today
with understanding that we want to have
bases in places that entrepreneur needs
and can help kind of minimize the gap
between being israeli but moving to the
u.s or we have a land but in japan for
example and working and even one in
india and how we can make the world even
smaller than what it is today a
postponer to our entrepreneurs so how we
can
shift them quickly and more fast
uh to the their their real markets which
israel is not a market so what why is it
in your belief that you know why is it
so important for startups to
to work with these big corporates that
that you're cooperating with why is the
why do you believe this is the
differentiator that could help a startup
tremendously scale
so a lot of
a lot of founders are waiting to build
the perfect product before starting
approaching the market
which i think it's fair and it's working
in some matters but
the market is changing so fast today so
what you build today it's not what's the
need for tomorrow
so with working with many potential
clients uh and with corporates that are
looking for innovation and now more open
to incorporating innovation before
acquiring it before you know taking on
the ip uh really help shape a better
product a faster product you don't need
to waste a year and a million dollars of
building the perfect mvp you build it on
the way you run with it and then you
reach to the market faster than you
would have reached with a perfect
product and people understand that like
the whole mindset have changed
i think right but now design
partnerships you know we've we've seen
this you know throughout the last few
years
being a very big part of the story here
is is this what this is about is it
about design partnerships or is there
something else in the work with these
corporates
that that is different than how a
traditional startup in israel would
approach a company in japan in germany
etc
i think um
it's the flexibility in mind
to pivot quickly for the market
needs um
less than a successful poc i have on my
powerpoint five or six or seven or 10
corporates or companies that working
with me
more of how do i think as an
entrepreneur how do i think of
as a leader and how do i adapt to quick
changes and i think that what it can
give to an entrepreneur and that's what
we're looking for
got it okay so as you're as you're
looking at the day-to-day now you're
looking at companies in israel what do
you observe
around you and you've seen the israeli
ecosystem evolve over the last decade
what are we experiencing today that
perhaps is different from before or how
in general are you experiencing
the the tech scene right now wow um
so what i see now it's not what i saw
half a year ago and not what i saw a
year ago i think we have an ecosystem on
steroids
it's not only
valuation or the size of rounds or
you know
it's it's a fast environment
you
build fast products
and i think
the scalability of israeli entrepreneurs
today
is much bigger and faster than it was a
half a year ago and a year ago both from
what we see and happening with you know
all the ipos and the specs and and
really
the
big visions that are now coming into
reality from founders that we know we
grow up with we want to be there we like
the world is you know it's small right
now
and and and both with everything is now
faster you invest it for us will you
invest in a company half a year later
you have a following round
it doesn't used to be like that it was
you know a year and a half between
rounds and if it's super rapid is a year
and you do a safe now no you invest
after half a year there is another round
the growth round can be in a year from
your seed investment
and you need to move faster as an
investor and the entrepreneur as i said
need to build products that are more
agile and more adaptive into what's
going on in the environment
but also by the way also the traction
needs to come faster than it used to be
right so i'm hearing all around there's
different expectations from all parties
how does this change your work on the
day-to-day basis how does it change the
way that you that you think about a deal
how does it change the way that you do
your due diligence
um so i think also here uh you need to
be
faster than you used to be you cannot
take your time to do a three months due
diligence on a company by the way that's
why we we have our studio that companies
even before invest investment can come
and work with us and validate their
product and we work together and we just
get to know each other and then we can
invest or they can choose to invest
um
i think you need to uh make faster
decisions
like
you need to you know if you invest or
not uh you can't really take your time
um in that kind of uh atmosphere
does that mean that natively we might be
making or intuitively we might be making
worse decisions than perhaps five ten
years ago or what is the compromise of
this versus what are the upsides of this
yeah there is a compromise first of all
you're gonna lose deals
right good deal
for me it's hard even though i say that
this is what you need to do it's still
hard for me to make a very very fast
investment decision
um so you will lose more deals some of
them will be amazing and some of them
you shouldn't invest
um and also you will need to use your
network uh in doing your dd you're not
the smartest person in the room not me
not my partner not our other partners we
want to use people that work with us and
work with us in the past and our
industry expert to validate the company
and then aggregate it into
you know our investment memo and what we
think
all the information we think we we need
to have right and we definitely need to
use a lot of expert to
kind of combine the minds of doing the
due diligence
and in your own mind where are we headed
right now so we've seen this dramatic
shift in the last five to ten years
what's you know with and ventures a new
fun you're going to be there for a while
what's going to happen in the next five
to 10 years do you think
i think we're gonna see um i think this
period probably gonna last for and again
i'm not uh
i don't know but um
i i think what we see today will stop
eventually i would i'm talking about
um
maybe we'll say like a little bit of
higher valuation that are not attached
really to the the revenue and the
potential profit of the companies
um and i think that the companies that
are building
a true deep technology uh um
and raise the right round right now the
big rounds will probably will be there
uh to last okay so it's a good time to
raise money if you can raise the money
and raise the rounds that you think you
should have
to be able to have the capital
uh in in the following years because i i
do think it's a little bit of a bubble
right
that will explode soon got it so
obviously i i think that's it that's an
advice that i've been hearing from from
from a lot of people and i think it's
it's a question of time and uh and i
think it's a very very interesting time
to be an investor an entrepreneur
anybody in the field lee take me back a
little bit to your own you know
childhood and journey and
what really sparked your curiosity you
mentioned that you were really into
politics and diplomacy
back before you were chief of staff now
you're into the text in entrepreneurship
and innovation
growing up what were you really curious
about
i i uh
wow so many things um
i would say it's a i was always curious
about uh kind of
breaking the the glass ceiling
i always like to take myself one step
forward and try to uh do things that
that it'll be hard for me or that i
wouldn't do
um i did go with my passion when i
studied history and political science
because i did find politics interesting
for a long long time
i was a tour guide
for many
18 to 26
um
so standing in front of an audience by
the way a lot of my investors was
met me 15 or 16 or 18 years ago and i
was there too early when they came with
their families
so
i think it gave me confidence uh
a sense of roots where i'm from what i
want to do what was here in the past you
know you're looking at even just looking
at israel
three thousand years ago two thousand
years ago um
the fraudulence of being here
and that you need to really try and live
the best and do the best for the time
that you're here
i think reflected me and influenced me a
lot
um
so i hope it answered the question
because it was um i'm super curious so
many many things and i can only assume
that this curiosity then translates you
know immediately into your work today as
you're meeting different companies on a
daily basis and working on different
verticals what what inspires you today
as you wake up every day new companies
working with portfolio companies
building the fund what where do you
where do you gain your inspiration from
um from from
a few places um my i would say my family
inspires me a lot
of how i want this world to be for my
girls um
and and and my partners i have great
partners my my co-partner roy inspires
me every day uh and the founders that we
work with definitely even the one that
we're not investing with it's every day
is to meet you know five or six founders
and their great idea and their great
vision and the ability to help and more
than that the ability to learn so i find
a home to my curiosity in tech
which is great i love it and if you had
to choose a few words to describe
yourself
or if i were to ask rory what would he
choose to describe lee what would they
be
okay he would say
some fun
i'm brave um
and then and i would say a leader
like
now i can say it uh after many years so
i think that's how i will describe
myself or hopefully other will describe
me than me describing myself
thank you very very much this was
wonderful i loved
hearing your journey and best of luck
with and ventures i look forward to
co-investing together and and seeing
some amazing amazing stories come out of
this scale-up nation and thank you very
much for everything take care thank you
mike
of course
you